my name is Stuart Russell and I'll be
moderating this panel which is on the
future of human-computer interaction and
just to reintroduce our panel members we
have guru Vannevar who is responsible
for beating Watson at IBM the next
generation Watson systems we have sherry
Turkle from MIT who's an expert on the
relationship between people and
technology we have cynthia brazil from
MIT who is a social robot assist and
also an entrepreneur the founder of the
geebo company and we have Barbara grosse
from Harvard who works in the natural
language area is a pile a pioneer on the
topic of dialogue and on cooperation
between humans and machines so let me
open the panel by saying that we're all
very familiar with the interfaces that
we have now with our laptops with our
smartphones and they seem fairly
seamless except sometimes they're very
irritating when they don't quite work
right you might be interested to know
that that kind of interface was
described in a fair amount of detail in
1909 by e/m Forrester in a story called
the machine stops he describes something
that seems very much like an iPad with
video chat capabilities climate control
buttons and all sorts of stuff like that
so what we're gonna talk about today is
what comes next and how will our
relationship with machines change as
they become more and more intelligent so
I want to begin by asking Cynthia to
talk about what's going on now
and where is the trend where is the
technology of human-computer interface
going sure so I thought I would just
start to highlight the diversity of
embodiments of computation that's
happening right now so more from the
commercial landscape what we're seeing
right now is a whole ecosystem
developing around hardware which makes
it much more rapid and iterative to be
able to create hardware of different
kinds of embodiments and this is also
really to
related to advancements in 3d printing
and so forth so whereas many of us are
familiar with kind of the traditional
boxy type out it's wipeouts at sort of
interaction with computers we're
starting to have this whole Internet of
Things and wearables where the
computation is becoming more physically
intimate so whether it's the Apple watch
or herbal watches or Google glass we're
starting to see these kinds of
interfaces VR headsets and so forth are
coming up that literally try to trick
the brain by beaming you know light
signals into your your eye to make it
feel like you're that much more immersed
in the experience we have robots of
course that are articulate and able to
move around and interact with us
sometimes in a social way sometimes in
another more tool like way we're
starting to of course there's
prosthetics right we think about Lake
prosthetics or arm prosthetics robots
that are becoming more of an extension
of ourselves that's another form of
computation and as we think into the
future we're starting to move into a
more intimate fusing of biology with
hardware so things like neural brain
machine interfaces neural implants we're
starting to see artificial retina we are
familiar with cochlear implants that
allow blind people to start to see again
or deaf people to hear again and I think
you know when I think about looking
ahead one of the things that's always
fascinated me about biological systems
that we can't do in our still a can
based technology yet is that biological
systems can heal and they can grow and
our silicon technology can't do that so
I can imagine I think there's work going
on at MIT in other places we're starting
to treat biological materials as an
engineering material itself so can you
actually design and print out neural
structures as an engineering endeavor
rather than studying an existing brain
or muscles and things like that so I
think there's many directions this is
going in and can go in so hey you ain't
seen nothing yet so sherry when you hear
this does that make your skin crawl a
little bit no I I think that I basically
the way I see it is that what we have to
get used but we have to get better at as
people as humans and we were just
chatting about this we couldn't wait we
started even chatting
before we came on it's understanding
kind of where our vulnerability is as
humans two things that start to make us
feel less human in a bad way so when I
hear about a cochlear implant that will
enhance the ability to see to hear and
all the implants I'm thinking great
no skin is crawling you know it feels to
me like an enhancement in all of the
best ways where I begin to feel I want
us to be vigilant is when an interface
or a computational object starts to
intrude on an area or pretend to be a
thing that it really can't do the way
people can and where we will somehow
trick ourselves into getting less than
we deserve to have so for example and
this is a conversation that Cynthia and
I have had some time if you create a
computer best friend that comes out of
the box as I think hello Barbie may
promising hi I'm hello Barbie I have a
sister I get mad at her do you have a
sister too to a child who might have a
sister and might want to have that
conversation they are hearing pretend
empathy from a creature that doesn't
have any to give and I don't think you
can learn empathy from a creature that
has that that does it hasn't had that
empathic experience so the question
becomes why make robotic interfaces in
this case do something that they kind of
can't follow up on can't really deliver
on and it may cause us to forget what
the real thing is so but but other than
touching on those kinds of areas where I
think we're quite vulnerable
no snow crawling at all no so you don't
worry about us merging our physical
brains with electron
augmentation for example prosthetic
memory might be a possibility that we
could augment short-term memory so that
we would have significantly greater
cognitive capacities than we currently
have does that worry you
well um yes but in the sense that I
think we're gonna get better at
understanding our vulnerability to why
we want to begin to do that for medical
reasons see I think a lot of these
technologies are going to be developed
for medical reasons people who have
Parkinson's people who I mean the
technology for working on memory and
computation is going to be developed
because of medical issues so I don't
think this is the technology where
you're going to stop the research or
should you and then I think we're going
to have to get better at figuring out
well what are the what are the places
where we don't want to use it but this
is coming up not just in computation but
in every area of our dealing with the G
with the gene with the with every with
with every area of scientific life and I
think that's where we I think that's
where we have to get better is
understanding as people where we you
know what are the institutions that we
need to to bring us together to really
as communities to talk about to talk
about these issues and also where we
feel that we want to sort of draw the
line about parts of our humanity where
we think there should be a kind of
humanity or some people don't think
there should be a humanity they should
get their airing and there should be a
public policy question Barbara okay so I
want to support what Cynthia and
sure-sure well sorry Cheryl said I need
a memory device Charles said and I wanna
I wanna just say a little quip as it
were the biologists have agreed not to
clone humans and I think AI researchers
should agree not to clone humans also
that there are many things that are
machine that machines and smart machines
could do for us as I said in the earlier
panel we know how to make human beings
and I think it's these that we should
think about I absolutely agree we should
not the science must continue scientific
inquiry is important it's back to gurus
a variable quote of you know what's the
danger of not knowing then the question
is how we're going to use these and I
would like at some point for this panel
to turn its attention not just to how we
as individuals are going to use these
but really to the use of computing in
the large and it's not just social
networks it's groups of people working
together and working together with
machines so what is the proper role of
people and of the machines and how do we
design these machines as I said earlier
to make us smarter not Dumber to
complement what we what we do and I
think that's a huge it's a design and an
ethical challenge for us to think about
what we want the machines to do so I
think it's hard to predict where the
hardware will go I think if you read
science fiction that's one of the things
that is often not quite right or they
way have way underestimated where we are
but it's this this other issue where
we're we're talking about what we would
like them to do so I'd like to just step
back and think about the objectives for
good user interface design and design
here right so it's one of the one of the
three very important objectives for what
we consider cognitive systems which is
to be natural in the interaction with
humans when you have a partner that
you're working with you want that
partner to be able to understand your
intent your language your gestures you
know all of the all of the above and you
want to be able to understand what your
partner is telling you in terms of the
information and the evidence and and
everything else of interconnections all
of that and and in some cases you also
have to consider you know what is the
model of the world within which we are
operating you know you can think of an
immersive
environment in which both your partner
or multiple partners and your
collaborators and you are working in you
know I want to give a couple of concrete
examples you think about a corporate
boardroom which is the kind of
environment that I come from where you
have multiple very bright people are
trying to solve a complex problem or you
can think of an operating room very
bright people trying to solve a complex
problem or a classroom where all of
these environments are collaborative and
it's immersive and you want the
interactions to be as natural as
possible so all the design for user
interfaces whether that's hardware or
software or the systems that we build
overall must ultimately go to what's
that core of being natural
here's an example would you take the
classroom of where you can make mistakes
because we are vulnerable in ways that
we don't anticipate to the to our
technology so classrooms have amazing
systems to use within classrooms very
seductive systems that keep students
involved with the technology during a
classroom and it turns out that it that
in in my studies of classrooms where
these systems are used the technology
becomes so engrossing that he can be
very hard for them to interact with the
professor with with not going on to
other parts of the network to shop or
you know to just check their Facebook
and so you have students who
theoretically have to have a great
system designed to enhance the classroom
a professor who feels frustrated because
the students don't want to be called on
because they're so involved with their
tools and students who have kind of lost
the gist and who will admit that because
they know they're on Facebook they're
shopping they're texting they're buying
and tailor shoes they're doing a bunch
of stuff instead of being involved with
the class those kinds of systems to be
not in terms of you know their cognitive
immersion exactly because you know if it
is a well-designed system for a given
task they would actually immerse the
students to do the thing that the
environment requires them to do exactly
but it means the environment the way we
often think about environmental
what retirement vulnerability doesn't
take into account the true environment
which is the classroom as a whole and
not just kind of the student in the
machine and I think that's really where
I'm kind of with that that we have to
make sure that when we talk about the
environment and everything that's
involved with computation it really is
our whole body our whole social world
our whole psychology all of the
relationships we're trying to maximize
in our life and not just what is the
interface between us in the machine and
I think that's where we've that's where
we stumble is when we think of computer
human interaction we somehow allow
ourselves to think about computer human
okay just the two of us there we've got
it covered when in fact it's the whole
wide world work to get us away from just
one person in one machine but I I also
have a quick reply to this i banned
laptops in my classroom for just that
reason and I have had any number of
guest lectures come and say to me it's
amazing how engaged your students are
and the students themselves realize that
the minute they get a little bored so
this is what I think it's both a design
and a policy issue the minute they get a
little bored they're going to go off and
do something else if that capability is
there so it is a very tricky design and
down trace I see in the audience some
blue glows on faces so we can we know
who you are so make the point we speak
about teamwork
between people and machines I think
historically there's been this
conflation of an order for to be natural
or to ative it needs to be human-like
and I think to speak to Barbara's point
certainly my own work I think what we're
finding is that fascinating design
spaces actually they're not human
they're never gonna be human but they
can compliment us in really intriguing
ways and the magic is celebrating the
difference and how they can help us to
be more effective than we would if we
were just people or just computers right
so I think that's the real opportunity
and I absolutely was sherry you need to
think about the whole Conte
that you're designing to support because
you certainly don't want it to be
distracting or to mitigate you know the
learning outcomes saying the classroom
you're hoping to achieve so just to say
again we as human beings we work with
non-human entities like you know people
you know might be working with you know
police dogs as fire you know as
policemen and so forth so we understand
this concept you don't have to be
working only with human teammates and I
think robots and other technologies are
intriguing to think about they bring
their own capabilities and I think
people actually can think about them as
teammates in a way that doesn't confuse
them with trying to be exactly like
humans in that process I also think one
really important thing for those of us
designing intelligent systems is to be
mindful of the adaptability of people
and that actually we should be building
machines to adapt to us and I one of my
current hobby horses as it were is that
the electronic medical record systems
have not been designed for the people
who are using them they've been designed
for a billing department and so we're
imposing on people to behave in a
different way from the way that would
allow them to deliver the best care that
they could deliver and I'm sure
everybody here has an experience with
some human-computer interaction system
where they have to change their way of
thinking and being because of the way
the system is acting so I think a major
goal as we look to the future is to
really enable people to use their
cognition in the best possible way
rather to force them to adapt to a
machine because we know how to build
that machine that way so let me ask the
whole panel if you can describe your
vision of an ideal future system that is
facilitating collaboration among
multiple people and multiple machines
what sort of scenario do you see that
working well in and how would it all be
like to be in it I can start sure so it
turns out we've actually implemented one
or two such scenarios today and I can
you know just describe one of them if
you are trying to make a really complex
decision as a group and you know I come
from the corporate world so I can I can
use a complex example like if you're
trying to acquire a company you know
which is a very difficult decision
because there's so many parameters that
you have to worry about there's a huge
amount of information that you need to
do research on and typically this is
going to have to happen within a few
hours maybe a couple days you know and
there's a lot of perspectives that
somebody has to bring in you know it's a
financial perspective there's you know a
business strategy perspective you know
channels perspective legal perspective
et cetera et cetera and of course the
you know ultimately there is there is a
you know an instinct about what's the
right thing to do kind of perspective
which is a value judgment that somebody
has to make so when you imagine all of
these people with different points of
view and different expertise come
together and ask a collaborator which
happens to be a machine all of the
questions that are in your mind compare
what is happening today to what we can
have in the future today a corporate
boardroom would have a PowerPoint
projector somebody comes in with a bunch
of slides and somebody asks a question
can we do this or not and somebody you
know another person says let me come
back to you tomorrow with the research
done with another set of slides but
that's you know really poor if you had a
real-time system that could answer
questions as well as project the right
kinds of parameters for you to consider
that's the kind of system we already
have working so you know is it ideal
probably not yet but there's a lot of
gesture recognition visual recognition
speech recognition dynamics recognition
between you know who is dominating a
conversation whether there are biases
happening that needs to be neutralized
what are the objective pieces of
evidence that needs to be brought to the
table all of those kinds of features can
be done by computer systems and it's
already implemented in some of our
running examples today I would answer
the question by saying that I think the
first thing that needs to happen
is for people to recognize the power and
the efficiency of the system we have now
which is conversation for accomplishing
human to human conversation for
accomplishing so many of our
interpersonal goals and of really
understanding the work it does so that
when we enhance it through adding
computation to it we have a very high
standard for the computation we add to
it so through example when somebody says
oh I know what we should do to this
conversation we should add a kind of
medical record where you won't be able
to look at your patient during an
interview with a patient will say is
physicians nah that's not real you know
the work the conversation does in that
medical encounter is too important to
just add something that primitive let's
hold off on that and I think that we've
rushed in to adding computation in a lot
of places before we sort of allowed
ourselves to really understand the power
of face-to-face conversations in some of
our most crucial human encounters with
our children with our colleagues with
our partners with our intimates with our
with our physicians so I think that a
more profound understanding for example
in the medical context means that the
next generation of collaborative
computational partners in medical
encounters really will be ones in which
there is a computational partner that's
adding to the conversation not
systematically detracting from it
because literally your physician is
facing the screen not facing you as you
speak and similarly just to finish up in
the in the in the in the context that I
study most which is somebody holding
holding a phone and somehow involving
themselves with a child I think we're
going to have industry and individuals
working together and almost the kind of
consumer movement turning to industry
and
saying you know how can we design these
seductive fantastic objects that that
that in a way that lets us do our work
on them in to involve ourselves with
them but somehow then release us make it
easier for us to release us to be in the
kinds of conversations we need to be in
with each other
ya know we've all been in restaurants
where we see couples who were just
talking to their cell phones and not to
each other and you wonder why they
bother to go together
I think that I think that that we're
going to begin to take that you take the
measure of the cost of our having been
so vulnerable and I don't think that
we're going to see that I notice I don't
think that's going to persist because I
think we're going to take the measure of
its cost okay
so can i yeah sure I just want to pick
up on this because I've recently been
doing some work with physicians and so
I'll give you I'll give you two examples
Stuart one is that if you have a patient
who requires multiple doctors they need
to know what each other is doing but not
everything so there's a huge when people
talk about care coordination but you
can't ask 15 doctors to each know
everything that everybody else is doing
it's a cognitive problem for people we
understand from our work on
collaboration that there are certain
crucial pieces of information that needs
to go back and forth so exactly to the
point that Sherrie made if instead of
having this screen in front what you
have is a system that recognizes that a
piece of information that one doctor
gathered is now relevant to the
encounter another doctor is having and
provides that information that would be
a way of augmenting this goes back to
Doug Engelbart augmenting the human
intellect understanding that we can't
see everything in this medical record
but there's something that's important
to convey so that's one thing another
another piece that's more that's
interactive from the other side is that
we know one issue with patients seeing
physicians is that they're afraid to ask
their physicians questions and I will
say even
even people with PhDs and law degrees
are afraid to ask their doctors
questions but if one could build a kind
of assistant to go to the doctor with
you when you can't take your best friend
that would remind you you wanted to ask
something or give you permission to ask
the question or even just you know make
a little sound that would signal to the
doctor that there's an issue again that
would be complimenting what we're doing
rather than interrupting what we're
doing so those are the kinds of near
term medium term collaborations that I'm
thinking would be very very important to
do whatever the interface would look
like I like to yeah so today when we
think about technologies today so much
of us focused on our cognitive selves
our cognitive minds and information and
so forth but we know human teamwork it's
also profoundly social there's profound
emotive factors of even physical
attributes so I think as we design the
future technologies in order to really
support the whole person these systems
do need to more to be more savvy and
capable on all of the dimensions of the
human experience
but to do it in the right way so that
you don't interfere with our ability to
engage these competencies I would call
them our signature strengths on the
negative side that could be
vulnerabilities but they're also our
signature strengths as a species to be
able to support us to be the most
effective so I think technologies that
address deeply our social selves and
emotional selves in addition to the
cognitive in the physical in the right
way is going to be really important to
create technologies that support us to
our best ability so let me go on from
there and ask you whether it's important
for machines to at least appear to
display emotions in their way in their
interactions with human beings and then
after that if you've seen the movie her
I'd be interested in your reaction to
that particular relationship and how
that evolves okay
so again speaking to the point Barbara
made and certainly in a lot of my own
work where I develop these social robots
it's a different question as to can you
create a machine that has human emotions
which I would say no because machines
aren't human and they're never going to
be versus what does it mean in the
context of that artifact in that machine
and what are the attributes of that
interaction that can be designed to
bring about the best possible outcomes
for the person so it's complicated and
it's nuanced I don't think it's a one or
the other right or wrong I think there
is a design space there's a continuum
there to understand deeply that's
fundamentally in service of the person
and what the goals the person has so I
don't think it's a simple answer but I
will tell you that a lot is technology
framing them is not trying to be a
human-like Samantha no which is very
much coming across as I'm just like you
must why do I think there's a huge
design space that's so exciting where
they don't have to be come across they
don't have to try to portray themselves
as being human at all and there's
actually an opportunity there and was
speaking to what Barbara was saying
about we interact with say companion
animals differently than we interact
with humans and they provide us with
social support in a different kind of
way
that we have that gives us value right
so I think as our Technology Center and
our interactions relations with them
evolve I think will be different what
kind of hands with with companion
companion animals says social support
companion animals not human species
different kind of experience but a
different kind of social support because
of that so I think as our technologies
evolve we're gonna figure out the
nuances of this but it's not a it's
exactly like a relationship that already
exists because it's just not gonna be
there and I don't think it's an
interesting question to ask us how we
get it since there is supposed to be
controversial I'll try and take an even
stronger stance I have to tell you I
couldn't really watch her but I did
watch X not gonna come so it's the same
it's the same question I think we should
not build machines that try to look like
people I think that our intelligent
machines should do their best to make it
clear when they're not people and is
for some of the reasons that sherry and
Cynthia have brought up I think it's not
easy to do that because we do very
easily attribute agency to anything that
acts like an agent
so I I would actually go go further I
think one of the challenges that I'm
looking especially if the two of you is
that to have and going back to gurus
point of having a natural interaction is
that there is a certain level of
conveying emotionality conveying social
interaction that's important to have a
successful interaction with a person so
how do you do that without misleading
the person into thinking that you're
human I think actually there it was it
was a project of Cynthia ISM has always
been a model for me about the
appropriate fluidity that you need in
terms of body and economy of gesture and
sort of knowingness that a robot should
have in its embodiment that has always
been a model of kind of appropriate
robot empathic behavior and that's the
astronaut assistant I mean they're you
up there you are in space and you're
you're fixing something out there in
space and you know typing a message to
your robot assistant is clearly not the
way it's gonna happen most effectively
but going you know is the way you know
that's the way ah is the way you're
going to express urgency because that's
what you're gonna be doing and you
certainly want your robot to understand
that that means I'm in trouble as
opposed to you know trouble or SOS or
something so with it we know that with
enormous economy of gesture we know how
I would know to express if I wasn't
feeling well out here and I know that
you know four people would come to my
help that's what you want from your
robot now it seems to me that's
appropriate where a robot and this is
why I say that I think we need to use
our smarts as people to come up with
this and we can a robot to pretend
to understand something about death
dying los sisters jealousy these are
these are areas in which a robot a robot
friend a robot companion the kinds of
robots there that certainly her comes
right out and says I know all about love
here I go you know I'm for you the these
robots to me feel as though they're
touching on something they don't know
and only demeaning what we do were in a
way that a cat doesn't because it has
its own kind of connection and is proud
to show it off
I'm Susan II where I thought I was gonna
add that you know whether it's embodied
or disembodied right these cognitive
systems as we think about it should have
a model of I mean not just of the world
but of specifically of us or a bunch of
collaborators partners and of itself in
order to have a you know a better
understanding of what the goal of the
interactions are and and so in that to
that extent I think it's important to
have at least some information about
what state one of the collaborators is
in or all of the collaborators are in so
it can you know you can guide in the
right way so there's this model of what
I think in the extreme we in AI we think
about it as theory of mind which i think
is a very far out goal but I think in
even in the small in the short-term you
can have state of mind as as an
important element of the interaction so
so we know from studying dialogue but
just Stewart mentioned I did a long time
ago that you can't in fact carry on a
dialogue with someone unless you have a
model of their mental state and can
figure out their intentions we also know
that those things are very very hard to
do well in a computing system
and I think those are also important
goals as we as we look forward and it's
I will say it's hard enough to do have a
system that can model one person but
I'll try one more time what about all of
these social networks what about all of
the connectivity we have now I mean so
we started this with Cynthia talking
about the new materials and what
difference they'll make but there's a
whole different level of human-computer
interaction going on now or a whole
different level of human interaction
going on now using computers and one
might ask could computers play an
important role in things like the
running of cities this is this is
something that I'm I'm chairing this AI
100 a 100 year study of AI that's gonna
take that's at Stanford that's gonna
take the pulse of AI every five years
over a hundred years I mean one can
imagine many wonderful uses of smart
systems in supporting people in much
larger groups getting things
accomplished and you know how do we what
does the interaction style look they're
how do we complement human cognition in
that to follow on with that so you know
in thinking about the future of
intelligence you know the we often think
of it in terms of like you know one
human mind one human brain that's kind
of what we need to understand but you
know in our opening remarks to the Nobel
Prize the Nobel Week you know it's very
clear that we face so many of these
global challenges and we live in this
world that's in to me connected our
actions down now at the level of
individuals have impact right and so the
one thing that we as humans are still
not good at is you know call it global
intelligence how can we as a planet as a
people all over the planet make
decisions learn adapt perform actions
for the global good we're just we're not
good at that and you know with climate
change and all these things we're facing
the point where either through our
action or inaction it's you know heading
to the business I think the words were
right so can technology help us become
intelligent at a global scale so that we
as the people in the planet can
can address these these huge challenges
we face that's a great question so I you
were to ask one more question before
before we throw it open to questions
from the audience and there oh there are
microphones so if you have a question
please raise your hand and someone will
bring the mic to you so the question I
wanted to ask is to look further ahead
and if we do have machines that are much
more intelligent than us will they need
to hide their intelligence though is not
to crush our poor little egos by
answering the question about her which
was that in the end the intelligence
that was developed in her really wanted
to hang out with other AIS and really
didn't want to hang out with Joaquin
Phoenix after she had tidied up after it
had tidied up his his a book proposal
and had his you know has kind of
organized his files in his life and she
was ready to I keep saying she because
it was voiced by Scarlett Johansson it's
impossible not to imagine it is a woman
but I mean there she was ready to move
on to you know to others of her kind and
so I think this is our insistence that
we're going to create an object whose
really main interest will be hanging out
with us I think is also part of a kind
of a very old-fashioned fantasy I think
Barbara's trying to get us moved away
from this is you know let's think about
you know creating artificial
intelligences will enhance our life and
stop thinking them as our as our kind of
best friends yeah I think our premise in
what you said Stewart which is that they
will get it will be smarter than us but
I think they will be differently smart
from us and that's what we should aim
for yeah you know I would I would add
that it's you know again come back to
the goal of enhancing our life
bring us with our goals and intentions
so if you know hiding or showing is the
right thing to do in order to do that
that's the world model that the you know
the the AI system should adopt so you're
saying yes they should hide their
intellect affirm whatever it takes to be
the right partner you know is my view
okay so on that note I'd like to open it
up to questions from the audience so if
you have a question please raise your
hand and there should be three
microphones in circulation although it's
very hard for me to see from here if
anyone has a question okay down the
front hello everyone I had a question
which was bit more short-term in like
scale everyone nowadays basically
interacts with machines with like three
operating systems Microsoft Mac or Linux
I was wondering why do you think after
20 years there's still only three
operating systems three companies making
them is this good or bad I think we all
know it's bad how can we change it I
think it's amazing that it's your your
contention is that there should be more
or you through door that should have it
should have it should have narrowed down
to the best I think that you can't
there's seven billion people and I think
you can have one best system right so
you're wondering why there aren't so
many why don't I have my own personal
operating system yeah so why do I have
to use Windows 8 you know so I actually
this question has so much more to do
with markets and business models and and
you know dynamics there are well beyond
the scope of you know technology and and
and even society I think right but you
know at the end of the day there you
know there
are so many new ideas floating around in
the entrepreneurial ecosystem you know I
look at you know dozens of different
great ideas and which one will catch on
and which one will succeed is a much
bigger question than you know then what
the technologies are good for and what
people think about them today but I
definitely would say that many new
elements even if those companies don't
succeed many new ideas from those
companies will make their way into our
lives so I have a I have a flip answer
in a serious answer the flip answer is
the architecture of one brain seems to
have done the human race pretty well now
toast operating systems obviously none
of them is quite as well architected so
that's my my flip answer to the we
should we should maybe only have one but
we don't know what the right one is so
we better try a multiplicity as we do in
research I think that the the second
issue this the second more serious
answer is really related to what guru
said which is that there are there are
these systems out there there's a lot
invested in what's recorded in those
systems and what they're used for and
getting the industry to move and users
to move that is people who are users to
move is a rather difficult in the
industry question and challenge okay but
I ask if people who asked questions
could at least give us an idea of what
their students are not students er okay
we have one up about halfway up on the
right technology while it is important
for machines not to mimic human emotion
would you say about if it were to flip
is is it important for them to or would
it be beneficial if they recognized
human emotions and adapted approach and
even tone in accordance to what the
human they're interacting with this
feeling absolutely I think I think if
you know we talked about this
but before I think there's got to be a
recognition of the the intention of the
state of a person it's it's very
different when a computer you know let's
say a personal assistant like Siri talks
to you about you know some question you
asked about let's say you know you know
calling somebody or whatever and not
finding that person to call might have a
very you know different way of
articulating to you why the you know the
computer did not find the person if they
if the computer knew what were the
actions that you did before you know
maybe it was because you know the person
is not in your network maybe they're not
a friend you know whatever it is right
so it's very important for the computer
to be able to articulate answers to your
questions in the context in which it is
most natural to you just quickly to have
some perception of emotion when replying
as well so I don't notice that in effect
interactionism way I'm sorry what is the
point about if the Machine replies in a
way that a person if interpreters as
insensitive with that you have some
effect yeah I agree with you that that
it's it's important for the machine to
understand whether to answer in in in a
maybe a current way or an or a nice way
right and yes machines are very bad at
it today
and and that's why we get frustrated
with machines all the time and so we
need to improve and we need to not only
research but also develop a lot of these
technologies that understands the state
of mind but also I disagree in this and
it could be of interest I you know I
think that if our expectation was that
the machine wasn't trying to be a person
I think this is a theme that's come up
but the Machine was trying to be a
gracious machine
but not trying to be a person but a
gracious machine a machine that
interacted well with people but not a
person it would have addiction and a way
of addressing us where we would be less
vulnerable to being hurt and wouldn't
have expectations of its we wouldn't
substitute what you are very delicately
calling expectations of user state with
empathy and expectations that it
understands things that it couldn't
possibly understand
and we're really we could get into kind
of emotional trouble if it did so and I
think that's the that's the research and
design area where I think Cynthia and I
are sort of talking about where you can
get into trouble or you cannot get into
trouble depending on how we play it I
think over the next little bit of time
so it so I think what Cynthia was saying
earlier about animals I mean animals
display emotions and they're different
from ours you know dogs have a variety
of emotions that we typically don't
display ourselves but we sort of
unleased we think we understand kind of
what's what's in the dog's mind and that
that's said of that emotional repertoire
hasn't been developed yet for machines I
mean there's one emotional indicator
that they have which is some kind of
rotating things right which basically
says I'm sorry I haven't a clue and I
can't get the answer to a question I'm
just going to go around and round around
around right as opposed to the stripe
which goes across which kinds as I'm
getting there I'm getting there okay I'm
done so there's two different versions
of that emotion repertoire that's about
it right there's really there's really
nothing else that is sort of widely
accepted and understood as a kind of a
robot state of mind but eventually and
it'll depend on the capabilities there's
no point developing an emotion
repertoire that the machines
capabilities can't really support but
eventually I think we will start to see
a wider repertoire of emotions so you
know confusion how do you express the
fact that the system doesn't understand
the input that you're providing to it
other kinds of things like that will
will start to emerge in
yeah I think they're they're really you
you've asked a question that has two
sides one is what should the machine be
able to detect in the person and I think
the answer is it should be very very
good at understanding us that that's one
of the important things and the other is
what it should display to the person and
there it should display in a way that is
responsive to what it's a text in us but
still makes clear it's a machine and
there are many studies I think of all
the cliff Nass studies that show that we
we respond differently to machines in
some ways and similarly in other ways we
have different expectations of machines
than of each other and so it's important
to have that right signal processing
though I just want to say that you know
when a machine is responding in English
say there's so many more dimensions of
how to how to display you know something
that is maybe better receive receivable
by you alright and something that's more
understandable in the state that you're
in so you know once you get into in
event but not what I when I say natural
I mean language as is a very important
component of it it's not just you know
icons right and when you use language
there's so many nuances and that's why
it's so complicated and even then
there's opportunity for being clear that
it's a machine but there's also a lot of
challenges in not crossing that line and
giving the impression that you know it
actually understands to continue this
conversation but but I'm hitting the
hook it's time for us to to wrap up so
I'd like to thank the panel and the
audience for their questions and the
answer is we ain't seen nothing yet and
is complicated